When talking about antigen-presenting cells,
we learned that they can swallow it first.
I will draw my best
dendritic cell.
Perhaps it should be simpler.
The dendritic cell is a phagocyte and is antigen-presenting
cell.
After the phagocytosis of some pathogen, she did
fragment and represent
the antigen on its surface of a protein complex. I will paint it in red.
The crushed part of the pathogen
is placed here.
In the clip for antigen-presenting cells,
that this complex here is MHC Class II.
MHC means & quot; major histopathoblastic complex & quot ;.
& Quot; Histocompatibility & quot; means compatibility of tissues.
This is the case for antigen-presenting cells.
Even B-cells do it.
I will draw a B-cell.
It has membrane bound
antibody. Here it is.
In fact, they are thousands.
I will draw a few, but know that
are more than one.
Perhaps one of them is triggered or attached
to some floating virus, protein or bacteria.
The cage absorbs and crushes it
just like a dendritic cell.
I will tear some of it and present it to the surface
on MHC class II.
I repeat, this is MHC class II.
These professional antigen-presenting cells
pull out bodies flying
in the fluids of our bodies.
They swallow them up, declare they are bad, crush them
and present them on MHC Class II.
That's why we call them professional antigen-presenting
cells.
It turns out that this applies to almost all cells in the human body.
I say "almost everyone" because I mean
all eukaryotic cells.
The only cells that have no core,
in the human body they are
red blood cells. This is extremely interesting.
So they have more storage space for hemoglobin.
All eukaryotic cells in the human body have
another major histocompatibility complex,
called MHC Class I.
These are also eukaryotic cells
therefore they also have MHC class I
right here.
Interestingly, every human
eukaryotic cell has MHC class I, besides
of red blood cells.
If something unusual happens
in the cage - for example
it is malignant and produces strange proteins,
infected with a virus
or there is some bacteria or strange protein in it,
every cell in the human body can crush it,
even if it is malfunctioning, and
to present it.
For example, if the cell is malignant
and contains strange proteins,
represented only by the cancer cells,
and are not normal for ordinary cells,
this will be presented on MHC Class I.
For example, if I have some other cell in my body,
which is of another type.
She is eukaryotic.
For example, it's infected with a virus.
It starts producing viruses.
By the same mechanisms the cell
takes several of the virus-forming proteins
and presents them on MHC Class I.
and will present them on MHC Class I.
In MHC class II, this has suggested
of T-helper:
"I found a floating body.
Here's a piece of it.
Why do not you connect with him and do not trigger the alarm? "
MHC Class I says:
"This is not a floating body.
I'm infected.
I'm malign
and go crazy.
Better kill me.
I'm a virus and I'm producing viruses.
Destroy me. "
This message reaches cytotoxic T cells
and this is the theme of this video.
I want to make sure you understand
difference. First - T cells.
These two cells have T-cell receptors, but
T-helper binds to MHC class II.
This is a T-helper.
Only the T-helper they have
the right variable region,
which can be connected exactly
with this combination of antigen and MHC class II,
will connect to it, activate, and
will begin to differentiate.
Their version versions will trigger
the alarm, and their memory versions will remain,
if it had to happen again.
In MHC class I, instead of attracting a T-helper,
will attract a cytotoxic T cell.
Like T-helper, T-cell receptors
have a constant and variable region,
specific for this combination
antigen and MHC class II.
So maybe this cytotoxic T cell will intervene when
the cell becomes malignant.
This cytotoxic T cell will be useless and will not connect
with the virus to which this one is attracted to.
You will have to do it another cytotoxic
T cell.
The mechanism by which we get the variable region
in T-helper, cytotoxic cells and
membrane-bound bodies in B-cells originates
from their stage of development or
the process of ripening. Then DNA that encodes these variables
sections, is deliberately mixed.
In principle, we always try to keep it
DNA information, and here she mixes.
When a cytotoxic T cell detects something
on MHC Class I - do not forget that each
eukaryotic cell has this complex, it is activated.
For example, this cell says, "You look suspicious.
You have to die. "
It is activated as all activated cells,
begins to divide constantly
and differentiate.
It divides and divides into cells of immune memory,
in case you need to act again -
if this type of cancer appears again,
and effector cells which
do the killing itself.
This is an effector cell.
The effector cells also
are associated with carcinogenic molecules and malignant cells,
like this here.
For example, this cell is split
and here is another version of it.
That's how the cancer works.
Do it very quickly.
It produces strange proteins.
It presents them on MHC Class I - Chief
histocompatible complex,
then one of these cytotoxic effector cells
is attracted to them.
I will not go into details about
the cause of attraction and membrane-bound proteins.
You will learn more about this,
in immunology classes.
This cytotoxic T cell is forcing
this cell to commit suicide in several different ways.
The first way is to separate a group of proteins,
called perforins. They make small holes
in the cell membrane.
It can also release other proteins called granzyms,
which initiate mechanisms,
causing the cell to commit suicide.
In a very general way
B-cells are extremely effective. When B cell
is activated, it produces antibodies that kill
different floating bodies.
When activated, it starts producing massively
antibodies.
They sail in the human body and can connect
with viruses, to defuse them
or mark them for macrophages or dendrites
cells and other types of phagocytes. Cytotoxic
T-cells kill cells,
which have slipped out.
For example, cancer cells they present
strange proteins. When the virus has entered the cell,
antibodies are useless,
because they can not get in
in the cage.
In this case, instead of clearing the virus itself,
the cytotoxic T cell will kill
this cell because it produces viruses
and must be removed.